des raisons qui ont cédé très attractif
je pense que c'est précisément son
universalité et sa simplicité
on sait tout le monde la reçoit
automatiquement à partir de certains
critères peut-être à la majorité un peu
avant mais cette automaticité rend
évidemment le modèle particulièrement
attractif dans le système dans lequel on
sait que beaucoup de personnes ne sont
pas qu'aux coûts à leurs droits parfois
ils ont droit à des aides minable qui ne
demande pas qu'on ne la reçoivent pas et
puis c'est un système des traits opale
parfois compliqué et c'est donc ça c'est
vrai que il ya une critique qui est tout
à fait légitime et que le et des
systèmes aujourd'hui protection sociale
devrait être un vif qui devrait
certainement être automatisés après ce
cette simplicité
je pense aux ce qui constitue le point
faible de l'allocation universelle
c'est-à-dire que les la société dans
laquelle on vit il gisait est très
inégale dans lesquelles il ya des
besoins qui sont très différents et dans
des modèles réaliste c'est à dire qu'on
peut financer qui ne demandent pas de
deux engagés va vous couchant du pib
donc admettons une allocation
universelle à 300-400 pas les 2 500
euros
cette somme qui est envoyé à tout le
monde pour certains qui en ont vraiment
besoin elle n'est pas suffisante et pour
d'autres qui n'en ont pas besoin comme
moi par exemple il est absolument pas
nécessaire et donc très rapidement ce
qui fait l'attractivité du système se
transforme en une gigantesque machine
qui vise à déplacer des sommes d'argent
mais pas nécessairement dans les bonnes
poches pour donner juste un peu et
exemple pour abolir la pauvreté donc si
on voulait aligner les prestations
minimales au seuil de pauvreté
on pourrait également les automatiser
aujourd'hui s'il ya une volonté
politique de les automatiser on pourrait
les faire et ouvrir l'accès à toute une
série de prestations à tous une cale en
besoin ça pourrait coûter entre un peu
moins 2% du pib ce n'est pas gigantesque
c'est quand même une réforme importante
mais ce n'est pas gigantesque une
allocation universelle de 500 euros elle
coûterait rapidement 16% du pib si on ne
la substitut par d'autres choses sur la
joute aux prestations existantes et donc
pourquoi dépenser plus alors qu'on peut
faire la même chose avec beaucoup moins
et que avec le reste on peut peut-être
investir dans l'éducation à investir
dans la santé a besoin important dans
les maisons de retraite
donc tout ça ici il ya vraiment une
question sur voilà l'attractivité du
modèle est aussi au front son point
faible
parce que les besoins sont différents
ils ne
pas les mêmes cette universalité post
[Musique]